SP by Mary cool okay um we'll wait for
folks to finish filing in while we wait
for folks to finish filing in consider
submitting a speed
talk okay uh so now we are all back for
um Talk two uh which so recall the the
outline was talk one this basic par
which now we've seen okay not quite fair
to say we've seen it three times because
the last one was kind of but we've seen
it at least two and a half time so
hopefully we're we're uh on board with
that and talk two is sort of about what
we can do on top of that basic Paradigm
what are various techniques that we can
use to make that better um so quick
recap because I know it's been you know
a long 20 minutes or whatever um when we
last left our heroes uh algebraic codes
what was going on so we saw two problems
we saw the unique decoding problem and
the list decoding problem so the unique
decoding problem uh our goal was to
handle a number of Errors which was less
than uh half the distance over with less
than half the distance and for read
Solomon codes the distance um sorry
there should that should be times n the
distance is 1 minus r time n about and
so we wanted T to be uh about this times
n sorry for the typo and if that's the
case then uh you know we know when we
see this received word that there's a
unique code word we can decode to and we
want to do that efficiently we also
looked at the list decoding problem
where we allowed to take t a little bit
bigger um again there's an N missing
there we want T to be 1 minus r * n
sorry and uh the goal is to recover all
of the code words in that ball and
implicit in that statement is that we if
we want to do that efficiently that
there there ought not be too many code
words in that ball that's what we're
hoping for we saw an algorithmic
Paradigm to do this um which had three
steps one interpolate some polinomial
two assert that that polinomial explains
our Target function f and three use that
explanation to solve for f or solve for
some small uh POS list of
possibility um okay so this is what we
did last time we saw this uh saw several
examples of this um for both unique
decoding list decoding and what we're
going to do this time um you know for
the next hour or so is uh see how we can
improve on this there's still more to do
um can we make these algorithms faster
um people were asking about the
complexity and I was like polinomial
time do linear algebra whatever um we'll
see how we can make this faster near
linear time that's going to be our goal
for the second half talk um can we get
smaller list sizes and can we work over
smaller Fields right so last time we
were always working over these big big
fields but like often we really want to
be working over F2 how can we do that so
today we're gonna or in this talk we're
going to answer those questions so
techniques to improve this Paradigm um
so here's going to be a list of
techniques and along the way we'll sort
of see where they stop working and what
the open questions are um so the first
technique I'm going to talk about is uh
locality or sort of leveraging locality
so how can we speed up algorithms by
running them on smaller bits um this is
going to be real fast because we have a
whole two hours of locality later or
more by Elena somewhere um so this will
this will just be a teaser uh the second
technique I'm going to talk about is
distance amplification um so basically
one of the punch lines of technique one
is it's uh we can make faster algorithms
but at the cost of getting worse
parameters and so then we'll see some
techniques for getting the parameters
back in line after we do that the third
technique uh although want talk about is
alphabet reduction we'll see two
different ways to do this one uh code
concatenation and the second um I'll
just mention very briefly using alge
geometry and if time I have a fourth
technique um to talk about which is how
to exploit structure in the codes and
the algorithms uh but I'm not sure if
we'll get to that but if we do then it's
there if we don't then that's fine so
we'll talk about all of these different
techniques and yeah along the way uh
highlight sort of several open problems
and and what's still left to do here and
as usual or as as with last time please
do interrupt me and ask
questions yes so I anticipate I won't be
able to get to technique four even if I
don't get to you know some of these
techniques like that's fine like I want
to make sure people understand cool okay
so let's get started uh with locality um
and as I mentioned before we have a
whole talk series on locality later in
the workshop uh by Elena where's
Elena by Elena yay um so this is this is
just a teaser um but so the idea of
locality at least in the context of
algorithms for algebraic codes is we
want to somehow either make a big code
out of little codes or view a code that
we already have as being made out of
little or codes so let me see I'm just
going to describe this with a couple of
examples rather than a formal definition
this is a hand Wy thing um so one
example of this is tensor codes so
suppose we start with a code C uh subset
of of Sigma to the N we can define c
tensor C so this is going to be a code
with longer block length it'll have
block length n squ instead of n over the
same alphabet we're going to Define it
as follows so it's going to be the set
of all n byn matrices a such that all of
the rows of a lie in my base code and
all of the columns they lie in my base
code I look at any row or column I I get
uh something LS in the base code and
more generally you can define c tensor C
tensor dot dot tensor C in the natur way
so you take a m dimensional tensor and
every this one and that one and that one
and whatever need to live in
the this make
sense and this is some way of making a
big code where it has lots of little
codes in it because you know I have this
this code word in my big code and then
there's like all these little code words
from the little code floating around um
another place where we see this is in
multivariate codes so for example I'll
just draw a picture of B variant read M
codes uh so a b variant read code this
is like the B variant analog of the read
code that we saw last time so the code
words are again I'm going to think of
them as matrices where the um the rows
are indexed by field elements beta The
Columns are indexed by field elements
Alpha and what goes in the alpha beta
place is f of alpha beta for some low
deegree polinomial app so this is the
read M code the B variant read Moler
code uh of Dimension um or of degree at
most K or degree K minus one
um and this has the same notion of
locality in that we can find lots of
little read Solomon code words floating
around here so if I take any line in f s
s right so I have this like this this
space f squared and I look at any line
here and I look at the Restriction of
this code word to that line what I'm
going to get is a a univariate
polinomial right so basically just to
read Solomon code word so any line that
I take in this Square
um now the picture doesn't isn't quite
right because it doesn't look like a
field structure but you know imagine it
wraps around or something and any line
that I take in this Square looks like a
read Solomon code word so I have all
these like little code words from some
other code embedded in my big code uh
another example is lifted codes so I
could imagine instead of this definition
here where I say okay I'm going to
Define it like this and oh hey it just
happens to have this property that when
I restrict to a line I get something in
my original code I can actually just the
code that way to begin with like I could
Define it to be evaluations of all of
the bivariate pols F all of the
bivariate functions F so that when I
restrict to a line I get something in
the code right um this turns out to be
different this is called a lifted code
um and you might think that if C is a
read Solomon code that these are
actually the same that the reader code
words are all the things that restrict
to lines uh in some paramet regimes
that's true it's it's actually not true
in general un fact I think Elena are you
going to talk about
that maybe okay so stick around for
Elena's talk to see more about that or
ask me later this is a a cool phenomenon
that is not related to this talk so I'm
gonna Skip by it but it's a fun fact
anyway so these are three different um
examples of ways that you know natural
codes we can come up with that have
little codes embedded in some bigger
code and the point for algorithms is
that if we have a big code made out of
little codes uh well this this gives us
some algorithmic leverage because then
we can like run our decoder on these
like little code words like and Patch
them together somehow and the hope is
that well because the code words are
litter little then this is going to run
very quickly right even if I have an
algorithm for my base code that takes
time like N squared or something uh if
the the whole block length is n squ then
all of a sudden that's linear time not
quadratic time like yay um so that
that's the hope of course there are lots
of subtleties with this hope like okay
how do we patch things together like and
which little code words do we choose to
run on there are tons of little code
words if we do it on all of them like
that's going to be too slow um and you
know lots of things like that and then
the thing I actually want to talk about
here is that the the parameters are
going to get worse um so these first two
things I'll just sweep under the rug and
say for all these different examples
there are ways to deal with it um but I
I want to just sort of mention the what
happens to the parameters so for example
for tensor codes um actually feel like
I've just been barreling on other
questions I haven't said anything like
super precise but this basic Paradigm
makes
sense cool okay so yeah so we need to
figure out how to patch things together
you need to figure out like which of
these little code words you want to
leverage um how you do that is sort of a
case-by case basis but like inevitably
the parameters are going to get a little
bit worse so for example for tensor
codes let's say that your base code C
say it has like really high rate and
reasonably small distance so like let's
say rate one minus Epsilon and distance
Epsilon so we saw last time this this is
optimal this meets the Singleton bound
like hoay we have this optimal base code
C let's consider C tensor C it turns out
that to get the parameters for T tensor
C you basically just Square the distance
Square the rate so uh squaring the rate
that's still a high rate code like one
minus Epsilon squared is to first order
one minus 2 Epsilon it's still close to
one but the distance is now or the
relative distance is now Epsilon squared
we wanted it to kind of be like two
Epsilon so that's that's not good um so
that this is this is not optimal so
whenever we do this we're sort of moving
away from this like Optimal parameter
reg we want to be in um and so that's
going to motivate the next technique
that we're going to use I'm not going to
talk anymore about uh locality because
that's again a teaser for our latest
talk um but the next thing I want to
talk about is um distance amplification
I will go into a little bit more detail
about this and the idea here is okay
let's say we've done this local thing
somehow but now we have a code that has
a fast algorithm but bad parameters how
do we get the parameters back in line um
and distance amplification is a
technique to do
that so um yes the basic idea is we'd
like to transform a code we have into
one with better parameters ideally in a
way that
respects you know that like plays nice
with algorithms that we might have for
that code um and so today what I'm going
to talk about is a particular technique
known as AEL distance amplification so a
here stands for Alon Edmunds and Luby
after this paper from
1995 um and it's this this technique has
been used frequently since then sort of
in the algorithms for algebraic codes
literature um I'll mention just one
paper um this paper by karti m RI and
Sur from 2015 um just because I think
this is the first paper where I like
really like appreciated the power of
this technique but it's been it's been
used it's of in this alic context in a
lot of other places um I should mention
also there are lots of other versions of
distance amplification um so for example
you might be familiar with this sort of
classic AB
nnr distance amplification is also a
more recent version actually also with r
amplification by
and many others um but today just to
focus on one thing I'm going to look at
a okay so here's how this works so we're
GNA have two ingredients that we start
with the first is our base code so we
need a high rate code C and we'll think
of C as having a fast decoding algorithm
but maybe it can't handle very much
error so imagine this is something we
get after doing this locality thing so
we have a code C it's very high rate
like maybe we've tensored it up so it
still has very high rate but it has
teeny tiny distance we have super fast
algorithms for it but can only handle a
little bit of error corresponding to
that teeny tiny distance and we we want
to make it handle more error so that's
ingredient number one ingredient number
two is a balanced bipartite expander
graph um so it'll look like this uh so
it's what is this it's a bipartite graph
and it has the following sort of nice
pseudo Randomness property
uh where if I look at any set s on the
right small enough set s on the right
like this one and I look at the vertices
on the left and I ask how how much do
these vertices touch that set most
vertices on the left should touch that
set about as much as you would expect so
uh for example here um if I highlight
all of the edges coming out of this set
okay this set has size m over3 in this
example so I I should expect like like a
third of everyone's like a third of this
vertices edges to touch the set and
indeed that's the case for this vertex
that has three edges coming out and one
of them touches the set and that's true
for for most of these vertices but it's
not true for like this one this one has
two edges so it's okay if there's a few
that have too many edges but most of
them should have about what you expect
I'm not going to be any more precise
about this um like I said the first talk
was the one where I actually did a
little bit of math this talk very hand
Wy high level um you can ask me for
details later okay so this is what uh I
mean by balance bipartite expander graph
so what is this distance amplification
technique so say we have these two
ingredients we have our base code C and
we have our expander graph what are we
going to do so uh I'm going to start
with the code word from C and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to show you how
to transform that into a code word from
some new code that I'll Define by this
transformation so the first thing I'm
going to do to see is I'm going to chop
it up so I'm going to chop it up into
chunks of some particular size
and then I'm going to take each one of
those chunks and encode them with uh a a
little tiny read Solomon code or maybe a
folded rellan code or a code of my
choice that has the properties that I
want and basically the idea is I'm going
to end up with a a final code that sort
of mimics the properties of this little
code but like in a big scale and with
linear time
outs so I'll encode each chunk with a
little read Solomon code and uh now it
is expander time yay um there's less
enthusiasm now it's expander time yay
all right there we go good yeah so now
it's expander time and so what we're
going to do is we're going to take our
bipartite expander and we're going to
use it to shuffle up the coordinates
here like Shuffle up the the symbols so
what is that going to look like I'm
going to instantiate a a new code word
over here this is going to be our final
code word and I'm going to populate it
with the symbols from this code word but
sort of munged up according to the
expander so what does that look like um
so let's suppose that this first symbol
here oh I and I should say the the
vertices of the expander correspond to
chunks in in this um Vector here so this
first chunk let's say it has three
symbols in it it corresponds to this
vertex and the number of symbols in this
chunk should be the same as the degree
of the vertex which fortunately it is my
little example and now what I'm going to
do is I'm basically just going to ship
the symbols across the expander so this
Alpha that's the first symbol so I'll
send it across the first Edge over there
the beta's the second symbol so I'll
send it across the second Edge and Gamma
is the third symbol so I'll send it like
across the third Edge like that does
that make sense and then I'm going to do
this for all of the different symbols um
I'm not going to do that many PowerPoint
animations but you can see where that's
going um so for example down here if I
had like Alpha Prime beta Prime gamma
prime those would end up um sort of in
the symbols that were connected to uh to
this
vert does this process make sense it's
very obnoxious to write down formally
but hopefully a picture is is
okay okay and so then once we do this
this green thing here on the right this
is going to be our new code word and
here just like with read with folded
read Solomon codes that we saw last time
we're going to take our alphabet to be
larger than our original alphabet so our
our alphabet symbols are now these kind
of full symbols their symbols they
Vector valued so our alphabet is going
to be F to the S where s is whatever the
the length of of these little chunks are
does that make
sense okay so now I have a code which I
Define by for every code word in C do
this process get this code word and my
new code is all of these new code
words why have we done this uh let's see
what happens when we want to say correct
some errors and hopefully I'll I'll
describe the decoding algorithm and that
will explain why we wanted to do this in
the first place then we'll kind of wave
my hands about analyzing it okay so
suppose that there are some errors and
remember my symbols here are these big
Mega symbols so that means errors are
going to occur at the level of Mega
syers like that so say there's some
errors like that and let's let's see
what the decoding algorithm does so the
first thing we're going to do at least
as a thought experiment is kind of like
let's imagine propagating these errors
backwards to where they came from so
we're going to propagate them sort of
back across the expander graph and uh so
there were sort of six little symbols in
error here to Mega symbols and we have
these six little symbols in error here
but now they're all spread out over all
the mega
symbols and the property of this
bipartite expander was that right for
any set that looks like this most of the
vertices over here touch it in about the
number you'd expect and so what that
means is that most of the chunks over
here
have about the expected number of Errors
so what what we've basically done here
with the pseudo randomness of this
expander graph is sort of turned worst
case errors into something kind of like
random errors each chunk has about what
we'd expect or most chunks have about
what we'd
expect and that's great because if we
let's say Design This little read
Solomon code here to handle the amount
of errors that we expect that that means
that most chunks we can actually
correctly decode so let's try to decode
those little read Solomon codes and
almost all of them will will turn out
well uh of course there might be a few
vertices like this one that touch the
bad set too much and they have too many
errors and and that one's going to be
wrong um but it's not too many of them
so now now we're back here we have that
most of the symbols are correct except
for this one maybe so our next step is
we're going to just un chop things up so
again we get most symbols that are
correct except for a few that are wrong
but now we can use the properties of C
right remember C Capital C was a code
that had a really fast decoding
algorithm but it couldn't handle very
many errors but now look like we have
way fewer errors now than we had to
begin with uh so we can run C's
algorithm uh and that works and then we
can correct the whole
thing so so that's the basic idea does
this make
sense poose
questions okay so let me wave my hands
about parameters real quick like what is
the rate of this code and how many
errors can it handle let's say if we
want to do unique decoding okay well C
had high
rate this step of chopping things up
doesn't change the rate at all it just
repackages stuff this step does change
the rate and uh basically the the rate
of
this yeah the the amount that the rate
blows up in this step is basically just
by multiplying by the rate of whatever
the inner Sol code
was this step doesn't change rate at all
because again it's just scrambling
things up so the rate of the whole thing
is the rate of the original code times
the rate of whatever this little read
Solomon code is if the rate of the
original code is close to one then the
rate of this whole thing is close to the
rate of whatever the original rate
onement code was and how many errors can
it correct well the error correction was
really based on what could the little
inner read Solomon code do um you know
with like the expected number of Errors
so it can correct basically the fraction
of errors that the original resol code
could so that's great we've inher this
optimal tradeoff between rate and
distance from the readed Solomon code
but now we actually have a much longer
code right how long does all this
algorithm take like what's what's the
complexity of this algorithm okay
munging up symbols can be done in
basically linear time uh decoding right
maybe this is
slow you know relative to these little
block lengths but these are really short
so overall this is also really fast
basically linear time uh and then un
chopping and correcting right the whole
point was that see have this really fast
maybe near linear time decoding
algorithm so altogether this whole
decoding process can be near near linear
time but we've inherited those optimal
combinatorial properties from the inner
read Al does that make sense cool uh
question if we use the folded read
solement code uh what changes great yeah
so what changes if we use a folded read
solement code so for Unique decoding not
too much but this is a perfect segue
into my next slide what if we want to do
list decoding or yeah a question about
so the in the last column you say okay
I'm going to attack this block of three
letters as my larger
letter um but so I'm just curious like
why like why is that my error model
versus an advis serial error who just
like picks his small letter great yeah
so the question
is like why is this allowed why can I
just say I decide the alphabet size is Q
to the S um
yeah so it depends on the application
and the error model that you have in
mind so you're absolutely right that in
a lot of different
settings like the natural error model
acts on bits and this is just not right
for those settings we will see next I
think how how to actually leverage this
for those settings but there's another
step that needs to be done however there
are settings where it makes sense to say
oh the natural unit of Errors is a large
alphabet so for example in distributed
storage or something you might say
what's the fil mode that whole server
goes down right and and in that sort of
model a larger alphabet size sort of
naturally makes
sense yeah thanks uh in practice do I
just pick like a fixed bipar you know
balance graph of every size or is there
like some notion of matching the graph
to the problem I have great yeah so the
question is how do I pick the graph um
yeah so yeah so I do need to match this
graph to the problem that I have in
particular what do I need I need need
the number of vertices to be the same as
the number of chunks and I need the
degree of the graph to be the size of
the chunks um and yeah typically I'm not
going to work through the parameters
because it's a mess but uh you know
typically this number of chunks is order
n and the size of the chunks is order
one and you there there exist explicit
constructions of expander graphs that um
for many such parameter regimes uh I
think it is a fair critique that you
often have to take n fairly large to
find good constructions of these um so
yeah there's some heav out there more
questions it's really good yeah in in a
practical application could you like to
get around the alphabet size thing could
you like randomize the choice of
expander graph and like send that
beforehand and then you know so that it
you know that you get around the
adversary is not able to know kind of
which where to concentrate its errors to
screw you up or does the question make
right yeah so I think the question is
like well there's two things there one
can I just pick a random graph and the
answer is that will have this
combinatorial property with high
probability so even for a worst case
adversary that that will be fine with
high probability but then also can I do
something random after the adversary
goes like the the alphabet the the large
alphabet size is kind of putting
restriction on the adversary that it can
only corrupt within you know a block at
a time could you get around that somehow
by like randomizing the choice of the
graph so that it doesn't know where to
concentrate its errors to to kind of
screw you up on the other on the other
side of the graph I see
um yeah maybe we can talk more about
that particular celestion offline but in
a moment I will talk about like yeah I
have a whole chunk coming up on like how
do we turn this stuff for big alphabets
into stuff over small alphabets and
there will be some Randomness involved
there and maybe that's certain close to
you're to maybe hold that thought for
just a little
bit yeah um is this still is this
transformation going to maintain the
linear the linearity of the code I feel
very confused when I see these blocks
being broken up and then right yeah so
the question is does this maintain the
linearity of the code sort of um so if
my original code let's say has these
little teeny symbols that live over
let's somefield F and this original code
is f linear then this final thing is
still going to be F linear because like
we shuffled things up but like
permutations are linear
right sure if your original code if if
like I guess it could make sense to
think about this is your original code
and like maybe these blocks were linear
over some extension field or something
and that will be destroyed um but yeah
linearity over the small field will be
maintained was there another question
that question Cool okay so maybe in the
interest of time let me let move forward
hopefully everyone gets the the basic
mechanism here um but I want to go back
to Henry's question which was uh
right here was readon codes I have this
little asterisk we could use folded read
Solon codes what would that get us well
what we saw the or what we kind of very
quickly waved our hands at at the end of
the previous talk is that folded read
Solon codes can do list decoding better
than read Solomon codes so this whole
picture was for list was for Unique
decoding what if I want to do list
decoding what if there's too much error
then these little read Solomon codes
wouldn't know what to do but if I had a
folded read Solomon code
I I would know what to do um and so this
is a good opportunity for a quick aside
on list recovery um yeah so the previous
cartoon showed how to do unique decoding
what about list decoding so let's go
back to this cartoon we're like halfway
through and let's say we want to do list
decoding now so the rate of the of the
inner code which should now be a folded
read solement code here is too high to
handle this amount of error right so
let's say it's a folded read Solomon
code so maybe I can list decode instead
of uniquely decoding uh and what that's
going to give me is a short list of
possibilities for each one of these
chunks and most of them are going to be
correct meaning that the right answer is
contained in those lists and some of
them might be wrong if there were too
many errors that ended up in that
thing and now we have the problem of
from this situation going back to the
original code word c how do we do that
right so the the problem here is we
somehow we want to go from these input
lists this a b CDE ef. YZ back to
C or to a short list of possible C's so
we want to generate a list of all
possible C's that agree with these lists
and this problem is known as list
recovery um so here's an informal
definition of list recovery uh we say
that c is list recoverable if given sort
of short input lists uh one for each um
one for each symbol you can efficiently
find all of the code words in C um
and uh you know implicitly this means
that there are not too many of them um
so that that CI lives in si for lots of
eyes so that's exactly the problem that
we that we just saw and this problem has
a name it's called list recovery um fun
exercise folded read Solomon codes uh
actually are efficiently list
recoverable as well as list decodable
I'm not going to work it out but uh hint
we already saw the algorithm so
you um the same Al
also okay uh so but what that means for
distance amplification is let's if we
take our little inner codes to be folded
read Solomon codes and we take that
outer code word outer code C to be some
list recoverable code with fast
algorithms which we'll say how get in a
moment uh then if you have a high rate
code that can handle a little bit of
error then you can transform it into a
rate R code that can handle the the
optimal amount of error for rate R for
any r that you choose and that that's
what this a just get so it's a very it's
a very neat
technique cool are there questions about
this before I move on
to so in the definition of list recovery
this S1 S2 Etc they can be overlaps
between them because the way you have
showed as if there were no overlap oh
yeah that's right yeah these s1's S2
they can have overlaps between them yeah
I guess I showed AB c d whatever just
because I didn't want to do sunscript
yeah that's
right yeah more
questions cool okay so where are we so
so far we said all right Technique One
locality let's come up with a code that
has real fast algorithms but real bad
parameters all right distance
amplification let's transform this code
to get the parameters back in line um
but as several of you just pointed out
like hey that makes the alphabet size
real big why is that allowed sometimes
that's allowed but sometimes that's not
ideal um so our next technique is going
to be two different ways to reduce the
side um and we're going to start with
code concatenation which is sort of the
most uh natural thing yeah so alphabet
reduction right so so far all the codes
we've been talking about have big
alphabets read Solomon codes need big
alphabets because they need the field
size to be at least number of valuation
points folded read Solon codes have
alphabet size even bigger uh because we
do the folding AEL this distance
amplification we just saw might make the
alphabet size yet bigger still uh again
this is fine for some applications but
you know like ideally we'd want binary
codes for many applications I just want
to take a quick aside to uh mention that
this is a challenge so lots and lots of
big open problems whenever binary codes
are involved um so here are some natural
questions you might want to ask about
binary codes what is the best trade-off
between rate and distance possible for
binary codes open right this is one of
the biggest open questions in coding
Theory um how about the best tradeoff
that we know to exist uh so this is
something called the Gilbert bar found
it is attained by a random linear code
um looks something like this uh right so
basically as the distance the relative
distance goes from zero to a half so for
binary codes the best distance you can
really hope for is like a half um Sorry
by binary codes I just mean that the
alphabet is is zero um yeah so as we go
from zero to a half the best or the best
rate we know how to get decreases
something like one minus the binary
entropy of Delta um this is not that
curve this is a curve that I drew in
PowerPoint but the the the way to think
about it at least like down in this
parameter regime is that if you back off
from this point by a half like sorry if
you back off from a half by a little bit
let's say by Epsilon then if you take a
tailor expansion of this you can see
that sort of the rate that you should
get is something on the order of Epsilon
squared so like close to this point this
is sort of like roughly looks like a
gra okay so right at least
this one I have an answer for what's the
best trade-off we know exists it's this
Gilbert Barsha bound can we do better
open question um however we can ask okay
so we know that these codes exist can we
construct them right this is also
largely a big open question so there's
been like really exciting progress on
this in the past five 10 years um so for
example TSH M's code which were a big
breakthrough in uh 2015 2016 like that
um and and related constructions these
can get rate very close to Legal found
sort of in this parameter regime where
we're real close to Ash so we now do
have explicit constructions of codes
there but in other parameter regimes big
open question and you might ask okay how
about algorithms for those explicit
codes uh so we actually we do have
algorithms for foros codes near linear
time algorithms which are are very
exciting um uh so for example these
works by jonos Shava tosani um and also
Blanc and donon for related code
construction these are
near-linear uh
yeah near linear algorithms for these
codes but again um for these explicit
codes but again that's that's sort of
only in this very low rate parameter so
there's tons of open questions here like
what is the right answer and how do we
get it you know these like very very
general questions um so there's huge
challenges there with binary codes okay
so with that backdrop let me tell you
how we can get close to
B um cool okay so the plan for alphabet
reduction techniques is first I'll talk
about code
and then I'll talk very very very
quickly about algebraic geometry codes
and then um we'll see in aside uh which
is this is probably where the Talk's
going to end um like what does all this
get us I'm throwing these techniques at
you what happens when you actually use
them all together what can you get and
what can't you get and that's what I'll
I'll do at theend okay but first let's
see this technique uh code concatenation
so this is like the first thing you
would try to do when you have a code
over a big alphabet and you want it to
be over a small alphab alphabet uh
basically you take your code word um so
it has all of these symbols that live in
a big alphabet and basically what I'm
going to do is I'm going to treat each
symbol as a little message and I'm going
to encode it with a little binary code
so let's say that c Prime is some little
binary code uh I'm going to take C1 the
first symbol here of my code word and
encode that with my code C Prime to get
a little binary Vector I'll do that for
all of them and then I'm going to get a
final code word that that is binary it
lives in 0 1 to
something make
sense cool okay uh so algorithmically
this seems great right uh in terms of
like decoding algorithms right even if C
Prim even if I don't have any explicit
constructions or even any good
algorithms in the paramet that I want
for these binary codes C Prime if
they're small enough then like root
Force counts as efficient right um so
okay I see some people being like uh
theorists yes I know um yeah uh yes oh
good even to a theorist uh open problem
uh make that better yeah okay um good uh
yeah uh but combinatorially it's it's
not so great even for a theorist right
because um the the final so when you
concatenate what happens is basically
you multiply the two rates and you
multiply the two distances so even if
what that means is that even if your
original codes both the outer code and
the inner code that you start with are
optimal their composition is not going
to be or the concatenation is not going
to be um so we won't be able to handle
the right amount of worst case errors if
we wanted to do this um so side note
actually uh this can optimally for some
flavors of theorists handle random
errors C4 these concatenated codes
that's a different talk but for worst
case errors this is this is not great so
instead what I want to talk about is a
technique due to tessen um and the basic
idea here and this is maybe close to the
question you were asking about is what
I'm going to do is I'm going to choose
different inner codes for each position
I'm going to choose them randomly um so
just random linear codes IID so I'll
start out with my outer code word here
and I'm going to uh concatenate it the
first symbol is going to be encoded by a
random linear code C1 Prime the second
symbol is going to be encoded with
random code C2 Prime and so
on so this is a random construction but
tessen in the 80s showed that this
actually approaches the Gilbert bar
found so this attains we don't know if
it's optimal but like the best trade-off
we know how to attain for binary codes
between rate and
distance that's pretty cool uh and
moreover the thing I want to talk about
now is actually if the outer code is
list recoverable which we just defined
um and also is in the right parameter
regime then not only does this have
optimal trade-offs but there are
efficient algorithms to decode it to
half to distance
right so we said that we didn't like
even though it's a really hard problem
to come up with explicit constructions
of these codes with or without efficient
algorithms actually there are randomized
constructions of these codes that do
have efficient algorithms what is the
outer code for thomason's construction
for approach gen uh any MDS code
yes yeah all it needs is yeah
any
other yeah could you give me intuition
for why the in this case with randomized
construction we don't end up losing on
the rate like why
the right so the rates do multiply
that's still true um with
distance I guess like the reason you
multiply the distance uh in the other
thing like in the analysis of the other
thing is that it's it's sort of a very
worst case type of of notion like the
thing that can go wrong is that if the
adversary chooses to clobber like each
of the symbols just enough to like make
them yeah yeah like chooses to
concentrate their errors like just right
and it can throw things off sorry I'm
not being very precise but uh
yeah yeah okay yeah and somehow this
this gets around
it so is the idea that the adversary
doesn't
know random coins no the adversary does
know the random coins this is this is
still a worst case statement
um yeah we can take this discussion
offline I don't have I I have very
technical intuition which won't make
sense when it comes out of my face
without a white marker yeah um does
anyone have like good short
intuition like the analysis works and
then it doesn't yeah yeah both of these
are not too hard to show so I
can cool uh okay yeah
but what I'd like to do now is give some
intuition about why this is the case
because this should
motivate like lots of people were asking
when I was like look we get these really
high rate codes with fast algorithms
over enormous alphabets that are list
recoverable like why do we care this is
why this is one reason why we might care
um so let me let me say uh sort of how
you do this um
so suppose that so let's take for
granted this result that these things
approach the Gil bar off bound and let's
say that t the errors is close to N
times Delta over two so we have we have
close to half the distance and we want
to correct it right so what does that
look like uh so here's our sort of
concatenated code code and um in our
picture uh we're going to have our sort
of geometry picture over here that we
keep having walk and then a bunch of
Errors get introduced and you know they
get introduced however the adversary
wants to introduce them so maybe this
whole symbol gets cled or something like
that um and here uh what that looks like
is this so we we know that the code
combinatorially is uniquely decodable um
for this fraction of Errors so we know
that there is a unique code word that is
uh T close to it right we just want to
find it so what are we going to do
here's the algorithm um and uh did I not
have AIT on this slide I think this is
first due to Gan indic um idea and then
has been built on since um the basic
idea is uh let's list to code each inner
code by Brute Force again because they
are so short and I'm a theorist I'm
going to call this efficient um and now
what I'm going to get is a set of
possible symbols for each one of these
these OU code symbols here right um and
uh again to Lolita's point I'm just
being kind of sloppy by drawing these as
distinct they could be they could be
arbit
whatever um cool and then this is a now
we can use our list recovery algorithm
for the outer code I have a short list
of possibilities for each symbol and I
have this uh supposedly now this hour
code that is list recoverable so let's
do that and now I get a short list of
possible code words so in this picture
maybe that short list looks like this
but combinator we know that only one of
them is close and if I have a short list
even a polinomial sized list that still
gives me an efficient algorithm right I
take this short list I check everything
in it I pick the one correct answer
right so by toess result at most one of
these things in this list is close to
the receive word just try them all and
find it and that gives us an efficient
algorithm to uniquely decode disc
contaminated code as long as I have an
efficient algorithm to list decode Or
List recover the the arode does that
make
sense
cool okay so punchline from code
concatenation here is that even though
it's open it's a big open problem to
construct explicit codes of rate you
know maybe like bounded away from zero
that approach the GB bound we can get
randomized constructions of these codes
and decode them efficiently um and if
you're interested in parameters uh hold
on for just a few slides and I'll I'll
get back to that a
second okay so how long do I have like
10 15 minutes
y Okay cool so let me very quickly say
one other technique for uh alphabet
reduction and that's um using algebraic
geometry codes uh so as a motivating
question we might ask okay why do read
Solon codes have such big alphabets well
it's because we needed lots of different
evaluation points right if I have just
one evaluation point and I evaluate my
polinomial at all of those points this
does not give me a very interesting code
right this is just the repetition code
so we need distinct evaluation points
and so we ask ourselves well is there
some way we can get more evaluation
points without making the field size
larger this is sort of very basic idea
of AG codes huge disclaimer I am so far
from an expert in algebraic geometry
codes there are much people who are much
more expertise in this room um but
here's my my real quick picture um so
take some nice algebraic curve call it
curly X this is my picture of a nice
algebraic curve as rendered in cover
Point um let's look at all of the points
on curly X that Y and
fq Y
fqm um and the hope is so many points
way more than Q points if if our curve
is like you know nice and curvy got lots
of points on it um and then we're going
to take our fun set of functions curly F
to be some analog of low deegree polins
um on that curve um so I think formally
you pick a bunch of functions in some
remod rock space and then we're going to
Define our evaluation code as usual so
take all of our our function that live
in curly F evaluated all on these points
in p and uh you know now hoay we can
take the field size to be smaller
because we got all of these points for
free because we use this cool curve so
punch lines is are that you can get read
Solomon like codes over constant sized
alphabets that are still amenable to
this basic Paradigm that we saw in the
first talk um you know interpolates some
polinomial C Roots um and uh in fact you
can even get codes over constant siiz
alphabets that actually beat the GB
bound you just can't get binary codes
but um there are there are codes over
let's say
f49 cool okay that's all I'm gonna say
about algeb you how many codes ask a
mathematician so I'll tell you more um
great but what I wanted to do to wrap up
the talk is talk about what do all of
these techniques get us so I've given
you a bunch of different Tech I've told
you about a bunch of different
techniques that we can try to use on top
of this this framework of interpolate a
polinomial and find some roots
what happens when we do it okay so
here's just one example so these
techniques have been used in lots and
lots of papers altogether but I'm just
going to pick one example um this a
paper by Brett hemway noar ranui and
myself from like five years ago or
something and this uses literally all of
the techniques we've seen so far on top
of each other which is why I think this
way uh okay and so here's basically what
this paper does you start with an
algebre geometry code that is list
recoverable so here's technique 3B that
we just talked about alak geometry codes
so so use one that's due to G Swami
enging um and then we use this basic
interpolative polinomial and find the
roots Paradigm to come up with list
recovery algorithm okay we have this uh
but it's slow the algorithm is slow so
what do we do we use Technique One
locality take a big tensor product
tensor it up uh and what we end up with
is a high rate code uh with fast list
recovery but really terrible distance so
it can't handle very many errors at all
okay what do we do next we do this a
distance amplif app uh and that's going
to give us an optimally list decodable
code with fast algorithms over a real
big alphabet um using that technique
that we saw and then we can concatenate
and do this tan technique that we just
saw and that's going to give us a
randomized construction of codes
approaching the GB pound with fast
algorithms can do that all together and
quantitatively the punch lines that you
get are so if we're interested in list
decodable or List recoverable codes
that's this box here we can get list
decodable codes with any rate r that you
want
radius uh sort of approaching optimal so
n * 1 minus r if you remember from the
first talk this is what we wanted
alphabet size very close to linear in
end uh decoding time very close to
linear in end uh and list size sublinear
andn so those the punch lines and if you
care about uh binary codes what you can
get is any rate okay it can't be too big
but at least it's can be as big as a
constant so anything less than .02 uh
and distance Delta um with approaching
the Gil barov bound so the rate is
approximately one minus the binary HP of
Delta um and it has unique decoding
algorithms up to half the distance
running in time near linear and the
one so these are these are all the punch
lines if I describe it like this it's
like well everything is solved isn't it
um but uh these are these are very rose
tinted glasses punch lines um so what I
want to do uh in in the next slide is um
maybe
take some of the the rose tinting off
and talk about some open questions that
are left here um aka the dirty truth
and uh yeah so the dirty truth is that
basically each time we apply one of
these techniques like they're very cool
and very powerful but every time we
apply one of them the dependence on some
other parameter that we don't like to
talk about typically gets worse um so
for example for all of those like
blowing punch lines that I said on the
previous slide um don't ask me what the
constants are don't ask me how big n
needs to be and please don't ask me what
the dependence on the Gap to capacity is
right so if the if the rate is going to
be Epsilon off from the Gilbert Marsha
found what's the dependence on Epsilon
um okay so you can ask me I will tell
you it's in the paper we worked it out
but it's it's embarrassing right um and
so I I think and and and I think that
the reason that we that I don't want to
answer these questions in public is um I
mean the reason is because I am a classy
person but uh the the technical reason
is because um yeah basically every time
we apply one of these
techniques something gets shot up some
exponential Tower basically um and yeah
so the big open question here a big open
direction that I really want to
highlight is that these techniques are
great and they've gotten us really far
but I think we need something new so
either a new way to combine these
techniques or different techniques in
order to make these algorithms actually
practical right like those punch lines
that I said on the previous slide sound
like they should be super practical but
no one is going to use this result in
practice for very good reasons and yeah
I I think that that new techniques are
needed
um yeah so this is this is something I
really want to highlight uh great okay
so I have like five minutes sure cool
okay so maybe I do even have time for
for my technique four um yes okay those
are techniques one two and three can be
very useful but uh I think there's a lot
of work to be done to make these
applicable and action practic s um I
want to talk a little bit about
technique four um which I think is maybe
more in the direction of of that and
this is sort of exploiting structure
that's maybe already present in the CL
in the codes or the algorithms that we
have so that we don't have to apply
these techniques on top
necessarily um I have like five minutes
so what's the best way to do this yeah
so maybe I'll just give the intuition so
like let's recall from talk one uh so
this is the bit that I rushed at the end
because I really wanted to highlight it
so it's good that I'm getting to this
bit did that that the gam me way decoder
that we talked about like the only thing
I told you about it is that it outputs a
Subspace right it outputs a constant
dimensional Subspace that's guaranteed
to conv the list and it turns out other
decoders as well also output similarly
structured lists um so things that live
in this inol polinomial and find the
Paradigm a lot of times they output some
nicely um and so let's let curly L be
the list that we want to return so it's
all of the code words that are close to
our receive for here so if we know that
our thing that that our algorithm
outputs a Subspace well that that tells
us that Curly L is contained in some low
dimensional Subspace so maybe the
picture looks more like this like here
are all my code words here's this low
dimensional cell Subspace that's
guaranteed to contain the list but what
what if my code avoids such structure
right then I I know that actually the
list is smaller than I thought it was
right it's not going to be this whole
Subspace it's just where the Subspace
intersects the code right so that means
that the list is smaller than we thought
and this leads us to uh a few different
Avenues to try to exploit this so the
first is that we can try to modify the
code like maybe intersect it with some
some Subspace Bas stent you something
that avoids subspaces or uh take
advantage of some other more precise
structure that that the decoder gives us
and and there are lots of works that
that have done that to very good effect
um and then there's another version
which is actually we can assert that the
codes that we were interested in
themselves already had that structure we
don't even need to do anything to them
um and I find this very promising
because like I said every time we do one
of these cool techniques things get
something else get swept under the rug
and so with this type of approach we
don't need to do that say um so here's a
here's an example of of how that would
work like suppose that c is a linear
code with good distance and suppose that
Curly L is this list that we want to uh
return and suppose that we know that the
list is contained in some let's say
constant dimensional s space then I
claim that automatically just from the
distance of C curly L is going to be
smaller it's going to be much smaller
than that low dimensional sub
space even if curly C is a linear code
like it definitely doesn't avoid
subspaces it is a Subspace but it will
still uh the list will still be much
smaller than than all of the
subs so why is this true so here's the
basic idea um and this is from joint
work with
um um from a few years back uh so
suppose that here is um this received
code word g right I want to find all of
the code words that are close to or
sorry not code word received word g I
want to find all the code words that are
close to G so what I'm going to do first
is let's choose a constant number of
random coordinates and just assume that
they're correct so I'll pick a Rand
bunch of random coordinates and be like
those are right I say so right uh and I
claim that when I do that that for any c
for any code word c in the list there is
a decent probability you might be small
but like bounded away from zero that c
is the only thing in my Subspace W that
agrees with this
advice so why is that the case so that
this has two components first that c
does agree with this advice um why is
that true so C is likely to agree with
the advice just because it's in the list
that means it's close to G so it doesn't
differ on too many places so if I pick a
constant number of places there's some
decent probability I won't hit any of
the differences so C is likely to agree
uh in these positions with G and then I
also need to show that nothing else in
the Subspace is likely to agree and
intuitively the reason this is true is
okay so I have some very low dimensional
Subspace like some constant dimensional
Subspace and it's a constant dimensional
Subspace of a code with good distance so
that means that all of the code words in
that Subspace are like really far from
each other and you can use that to show
that right basically every time
you grab a random position here and fix
it
uh you're you're basically cutting down
the dimension of your solution Space by
one you show with high probability this
is going to knock down the dimension of
your solution space because of the
distance and so what that means is that
okay you have a constant dimensional
space to start with if you knock it down
a constant number of times you won't
have any degrees of three and left so c
will be the unique thing in that list um
okay great so if you believe that then
all right what's the size of the list
well for anything in the list if I I
have this same algorithm that returns it
with probability p so if you just sort
of like do linearity of expectation
scared it for a bit you'll see that that
implies the size of the list is no more
than one over P which is actually turns
out these parameters is it's going to be
much much smaller than the size of w
itself itself so you can use this uh you
know for any code with good distance
that if the code has a little bit more
structure you can actually do something
even better um so what you get out is
that folded rol codes themselves um also
multi Univar multiplicity codes which I
haven't talked about but which prad will
talk about in his talk tomorrow I think
folder read Solomon codes themselves
with n none of these fancy techniques
themselves are already list decodable
with rate R radius optimal and list size
smaller than it was before um uh
although the algorithms are still no no
faster um follow-up work by karti R
ranui Sara and silus uh derandomized
this decoder the decoder I described as
randomized algorithm take a bunch of
random advice they show how to Der
randomize this and actually a very
recent work by tommo this is like barely
a month old has a simplified proof and
and better balance this is really pretty
I'm still processing this paper but uh
should this um but I think it is still
open what is the correct list size for f
Sol so if you're looking for
problem cool okay so I should probably
stop yeah all right so let me wrap up
real quick um cool so what have we seen
we've seen a bunch of techniques to
improve this basic Paradigm of
interpolated a polinomial and find the
roots so Technique One is locality
technique two is dis amplification
technique three is reduce the alphabet
size and we saw that you can apply all
of these things Al together to get very
good results on paper but there's a lot
of open questions when it comes to
making these actually practical and then
technique four uh is we can also
additionally um exploit some structure
in the codes or the algorithm um and
yeah and I guess I did this after
because my I didn't actually expect to
be able to get to it um but you you can
lump this in you can do all four of them
together you can still get lots of uh
all all of the things and of course yeah
as I mentioned there's still Lots left
to do um so those are the techniques
that we saw how about the open questions
um so I mentioned a lot of open
questions for binary codes right so
practical near linear time decoders for
even probabilistic constructions of
binary codes near the GV bound and then
of course explicit constructions of
binary Cod question in more in more
parameter reges than we currently have
them um and over large alphabets again
practical near linear time list decoding
Or List recovery algorithms and better
this sizes and I think if we could get
these hopefully I've I've convinced you
that you know if we get really practical
things even if the alphabet size is huge
then with this sort of contamination we
can perhaps turn that into better uh
unique decoding a
for but both might require new
techniques um so I don't know maybe
instead of my little cartoon Hammer we
need maybe a fancier hammer or my My
Hope Is that we just need a simpler tool
that we haven't thought of like like an
Ikea allen wrench I'm hoping
so hopefully we'll figure it out in the
coming semester okay so I'll stop there
it's time for
[Applause]
lunch
thanks tutorial and time for a quick
question if people have any many
questions during the talk I just want to
confirm the reason is that the doesn't
have
H to that's right yeah so the question
is like why do we need to tenser things
up yes because the original AG code if
we want a near linear time
algorithm
question is there ever reason to tensor
like different codes together yes what
would be one uh yes the question is is
is there ever reason to tensor different
codes together um
yeah so like for some actually I think
in that very paper we actually I think I
was oversimplifying I think we do one
different code um but uh like one for
algorithms sometimes you want like one
of the codes to have some nice
algorithmic property and the other one
to have a different nice algorithmic
property because then sometimes the
decoding algorithm kind go back and
forth and lever so yeah there are there
are reasons that youd want to Tor two
different things um I just didn't talk
about that all right maybe we'll take
remaining questions offline thanks
again
oh and uh he
talks long are
the